ارجع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الى يوم
الاثنين عقد اجتماع مع قاده الائتلاف
الحكومي لبحث تداعيات مطالبه وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي بوقف الخطه الحكوميه الراميه
الى احداث تغييرات في جهاز القضاء
الاسرائيلي يتزامن ذلك مع دخول الاحتجاجات
في اسرائيل ضد خطه نتنياهو اسبوعها الثاني
واتساع رقعه رفض العصيان داخل مؤسسه الجيش
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي دلالات تصريح
وزير الدفاع يؤف جالنت بان الاصرار على
مشروع قانون نظام قضائي اصبح خطرا على امر
اسرائيل وبان الانقسام المتزايده في
المجتمع يتغلغل داخل الجيش وكيف نقرا ردود
الفعل وتصاعد الجدل بشر تصريحات وزير
الدفاع داخل الحكومه على ضوء دعوات وزراء
يمينيين متطرفين الى اقاله جالنت من منصبه
بدعوى استجابته بضغوط المعارضه وكيف يبدو
الموقف الامريكي من ازدياد عمق الانقسام
السياسي تشهده اسرائيل وباهي خطه واشنطن
للحيلوله دون تدهور الاوضاع لدى حليفتها
الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه وما هي ارتدادات
الازمه على سياسه اداره بعيدا ازاء الشرق
الاوسط
[موسيقى]
من طور لاخر اشد تنتقل الازمه السياسيه في
اسرائيل بسبب اصرار نتنياهو على تمرير
التعديلات القضائيه وقانون الكنيست الجديد
هو ان الازمه طرقت ابواب الفريق الحكومي
نفسه بعد ان طلب وزير الدفاع
تاجيل التعديلات القضائيه قال انه لا
يعتزم العدول عن المطالبه بتجميد
التعديلات القضائيه رغم كل الضغوط مشيرا
لخطر داهم يتهدد دوله اسرائيل مصادر مقربه
من نتنياهو اكدت ان جالنت لا يستطيع
الاحتفاظ بمصيبه كوزير للدفاع اذا لم
يتراجع عن مطلبه وزير الامن اثمار بنجفير
طالب باقاله جالنت متهما اياه بتنفيذ
اجنده اليسار والاستسلام لضغوط وسائل
الاعلام والاحتجاجات مقابل ذلك حيه زعيم
المعارضه يا ايرلافيد ما وصفه بشجاعه وزير
الدفاع داعيا حكومه نتنياهو لوقف
التعديلات القضائيه فورا لانها تهدد
بتفكيك اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
لمناقشتي هذا الموضوع معنا منه تل ابيب
الدكتور دان شيفتان رئيس برنامج دراسات
الامن القومي في جامعه حيفا ومن روما
ميشيل عضو الحزب الديمقراطي الامريكي وهي
خبيره ايضا في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
اهلا بكم وابدا بضيفي من تل ابيب الدكتور
دان شيفتان عن هذا الموقف المعبر عنه من
قبل وزير الدفاع الى اي بدا اربك الحسابات
داخل حكومه نتنياهو والائتلاف الحاكم معه
في هذه الحكومه
لدينا فعلا مشكله خطيره في اسرائيل اذ كان
لدينا نظام
متطرف كان يعطي كل
السلطات للقضات اما الان
ذهبت الاتجاه المعاكس تماما وترجع كل
السلطات للحكومه
والمشرعين وهذا هو تمزيق لاسرائيل واعتقد
ان الجانبين يرتكبان خطا كبيرا حاليا اهم
خطا هو خطا تقوم به الحكومه لانه هم في
السلطه وهم لديهم المسؤوليه وان المناقشات
الحقيقيه الان ليس حول محتوى وفحوى
التغييرات او او الاصلاحات هذه بل الامر
يتعلق
هل هل ان هذا يمكن استمرار في تشريحه
كقانون دون مناقشات تجري من قبل الجمهور
الاسرائيلي وما تحاول تقوم به الحكومه هو
ان تعمرر كل شيء خلال بضعه ايام وان تحدث
التغييرات التي تكون غير قابله للرجوع
عنها على صعيد عالي وقاله وزير دفاع امس
ليس هو شيء ضد الاصلاحات هو لم يقل انه
يتفق مع الوضع السابق بل قال نحن لا
نستطيع ان نتحمل اجراء ذلك دون البدء
بحوار وطني لا بد من ناقش هذا الموضوع
بهدوء والجانبان مستعدان لذلك اوقفوا هذا
التشريع حاليا لبضعه ايام وهذا سيعطي
للبرلمان الاسرائيلي وقتا لان هناك الان
لديه فتره استراحه واللي بضعه
اسابيع
بناء على ما ذكرت الان اذا لماذا رغم
تبرير وزير الدفاع لموقفه هذا
ما وصفها بانها مخاطر امنيه ومع ذلك هناك
دعوات لاقالته وبانه اصبح يمثل اليسار
ويخضع لوسائل الاعلام ما تفسير ذلك
اعتقد ان هناك سوء حسابات كبير من قبل
رئيس الوزراء ومعظم الذين في الحزب الحاكم
في الكود فهم يعتقدون ان بامكانهم ان
يفرضوا التطبيق هذا القرار ولا يفعلون عمق
المشاكل التي ستحصل اولا في داخل اسرائيل
وكذلك حتى بالنسبه لاعداء اسرائيل فنصله
الله فعلا بدا
بتهديد والايرانيون بدا يتخذون مواقف
متطرفه والفلسطين ايضا بدا يزيدوا اعمالهم
الارهابيه وبالتالي الكل يفترض ان اسرائيل
ضعيفه اليوم وبالتالي وبسبب هذه الخلافات
الداخليه لن تستطيع اسرائيل الرد على
مخاطر او التهديدات الخارجيه السبب
الرئيسي هو خلل او سوء في الحسابات واعتقد
ان ثنياهو والذي فتره طويله كان قد اثبت
ان لديه مقاربه متوازنه حول معظم المواضيع
فقد هذا الموازنه وحاليا غير قادر على
التوصل الى شيء او لحزب اليهود نفسه لا
اتحدث فقط عن ما هو من مصلحه اسرائيل بل
ايضا اعتقد ما يقوم به يؤثره ويصير الى
مصالح السياسيه لحسبه واعتقد ان الامر
يعود اصلا الى سوء حسابات من قبله السيده
ضيفتي من روما
ردود الفعل داخل اسرائيل على دعوه الرئيس
بايدن حكومه نتنياهو الى
التريث
وايجاد حل نوعا ما يراعي الظروف الحاليه
قبل بدعوه للبيت الابيض بان يتدخل في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه وبالتالي كيف نفهم هذه
العلاقه الان
الامر مثير للاهتمام لان هنالك اجزاء
كثيره تحدث في نفس الوقت في اسرائيل الامر
لا يتعلق بكون الامور سوداء او بيضاء او
رماديه هنالك كل الوان الطيفه في اسرائيل
وما نراه الان هنالك تحرك واسع
للديمقراطيه وهي هنالك نظام ديمقراطي
وعندما نقارنها بالديمقراطيه الفرنسيه
التي دائما تخرج الامور فيها الى شوارع
لان هنالك الكثير من الاشخاص يصفونها
بازمه ديمقراطيه اعتقد انها ازمه
ديمقراطيه اذا ما كان لم يكن هنالك تمرير
القوانين بدون رد فعل شعبي ما رايناه الان
لدينا جلنت هو وضع نفسه في موقف ليس هنالك
نقطه تعود له هو فيما يتعلق بمنالته
السياسيه وضعها على المحاك ربما سيتم
استبداله وهنالك فرصه له ضئيله له
للاحتفاظ بمنصبه وهو الشخص هذا الشخص
يتمتع بمنصب عالي في الكنيست بالاضافه الى
نتنياهو هو ينظر الى الوضع اذا ما كان
هنالك نسبه من الاحتياط في جيش الدفاع
يستخدمون حقهم الديمقراطي وفي يرفضون
المساهمه هذا الامر يشكل خطرا في هيكله
الجيش وبالتالي الحفاظ على امن البلاد
بالتالي كوزير للدفاع مسؤوليته الاولى هو
اداره هذا الامر بشكل جيد وهو يعترف ان
هذا الامر لن يكون ناجحا اذا ما رفض عده
اشخاص ان يلتحقوا بقوه الاحتياط نصل الى
نقطه انشقاق قبائل يتعامل مع هذا الامر
بتجام مسؤوليته للحزب لحزبه ورغبته في ان
يعيد انتخابه وايضا بتسعين عضوا في
الكونجرس من ضمنهم كاوسكي والذي هو عضو
منصب عالي في الكونغرس ويهودي وكتب رساله
يطلب منها من الرئيس بايدن ان يتدخل وان
يحاول ان يشجع ان نتنياه على ان لا يمضي
قدما في هذا القانون هذا ايضا مثل
امور كانت تحصل في السابق حيث ان كان
هنالك تدخل في السياسات في الشرق الاوسط
ومن المثيره ان نفكر في هذا الاهتمام ان
محاوله الولايات المتحده ان تتدخل وما
نراه في اسرائيل هنالك رد ديمقراطي اكثر
من 200 الف شخص يحتاجون ويقولون اننا نرفض
اننا حصول هذا الامر بدون اي عمليه سياسيه
كافيه هذا رد فعل ديمقراطي بالتالي من
المثير للاهتمام رؤيه بايدن يتدخل في هذا
الامر وعندما ننظر اليها من وجهه نظر غير
استعماريه لربما نرى الامور بطريقه مختلفه
طيب الان التحق به من الناصره امير المغول
الكاتب والباحث المختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي وباشر معك سؤال سيد امير مقوله
الان في محاوله فهم المشهد كيف يبدو
السيناريو المحتمل اخر الاخبار تقول بان
وزير الدفاع ربما سيمتنع عن التصويت
وبالتالي لا يلجا الى قول نعم
او لا وهذا ما قد يفيده او يحميه من مساله
العزل او الاقاله وبالتالي ما ترجيحك
لسيناريو القادم
يعني كل الامكانيات وارده الحقيقه لانه
نتنياهو كما يبدو لحد الان ذاهب في اتجاه
الصدام اكثر
لغال في التشريع قد يضطر في اللحظه
الاخيره في حال شعر انه ممكن ما ينفذ في
قانونه انه يتراجع تماما لانه هذا سيسد
الطريق تماما مقابل امكانياته المستقبليه
في في التشريعات وايضا وزير الدفاع او
وزير الامين عمليا في نهايه المطاف هو
يعني يمثل موقف الجيش يعني وهو الجيش اصبح
في صدام حقيقي مع نتنياهو الذي بالنسبه من
منطلقات صهيونيه باتا الجيش يشعر انه تحول
الى جيشين في حالات معينه بالذات في الضفه
الغربيه وتتاكل المناعه الاستراتيجيه
والتكتيكيه
والجوزيه والكفاءات العسكريه وما الى ذلك
وتم الاعلان عن الغاء عمليات وهذا قد يدخل
في كل
المجالات يعني الامنيه والسياسيه
والاقتصاديه باعتقادي انه المرحله القادمه
مرحله حاسم اسرائيليا طبعا يعني
لمره اخرى بين نتنياهو ورؤساء تحالف او
الائتلاف الحكومي الى يوم الغد هذا يصب في
اي اتجاه برايك
هذا يصب في الاتجاه كما يبدو في الاتجاه
الذي يسعى اليه جانس الذي هو اصبح مقبولا
على الشركاء الحديديين او المدينين
المتزمتين طبعا ليس مقبولا على الصهيوني
الدينيه ولا على الاحزاب الفاشيه
ويصب كما يبدو في محاوله نتنياهو منع
اشتعال النيران في خندقه الاخير في الحزب
الليكود لانه اذا اخفق اليوم وغدا قد تكون
هناك قياده يعني واسعه او قيادات واسعه في
اللكود تتمرد على نتنياهو وطلبه انه سوف
يورثها حزبا مدمرا بعد انتهاء حقبته التي
باتت تبدو قريبه يعني في في المشهد
الاسرائيلي سواء نجح في الاصلاحات في
الاجراءات القانونيه ام لم ينجح في نهايته
عمليا في الحق يعني خليف حضور السياسي
وهذا يؤدي الى ايضا اشتعال يعني التوتر في
داخل حزبه وفي اخر قاعه وهو كان يتمسك به
طيب اذهب الى دكتور دان شيفتان ضيفي من
ايضا في محاوله فهم ما يجري والتركيز على
ما الموقف المعلن من قبل وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي وكما ذكرت قبل قليل بعض
الاخبار تقول بان وزير الدفاع قد يمتنع عن
التصويت حتى يتجنب مساله
اقالته وبالتالي ما الذي يجري الان على
صعيد محاوله فهم ما قد يحدث خلال هذا
الاسبوع لان هذا الاسبوع سيتم القراءه
الثانيه والثالثه للمشروع المقدم
اولا في اسرائيل كل القرارات الرئيسيه
تحصل حتى في اللحظات الاخيره فقط وبالتالي
لا يمكن قضيه توقعات حول من قد يحصل غدا
او بعد غد لانه
حصل تغيير كبير غدا ولكن ما استطيع ان
اقوله الان هو انه لو ان هذا التشريع نجح
وقلل فاننا سيكون لدينا مواقع مختلف تماما
في اسرائيل عما كنا نعيشه في البناء او
الهيكله السياسي في البلاد فانه لانه انا
ذاك لفتره طويله من الزمن سيكون من الصعب
جدا وصول التوافق اراء لا اعلم ان كان
الامر كله يعتمد على نتنياهو شخصيا لو ان
نتنيها وافق غدا ان يخاطر بايقاف هذا
التشريع لبضعه اسابيع اذا وافق على ذلك
فان الامور يمكن ان تتغير علينا ان نتذكر
شيئا واحدا ليس هو ليس بحاجه الى غالبيه
مطلقه
لاستخدام كل ما يريد تريد الحكومه لتعيين
القضاه حتى لذبح على 64 صوتا حتى على واحد
من 120 مقعدا يستطيع ان يسرع القانون
وبالتالي السؤال هو
لو انك غالنت هو واحد او اثنين من اعضاء
رفضوا التصويت للقانون
سيشرع ام لا ولكن السؤال هل انه سيشرع ام
لا السيده من روما عندما تقول التقارير من
قبل المسؤولين الامنيين والعسكري
الاسرائيليين بان الوضع الامني في اسرائيل
خطير وان مساله الرد على التي كانت بدا
اسرائيل صوره الرضع بدات تهتز
الى اي مدى اداره بايدن في حاله حرج تجاهه
حليف استراتيجي اسمه اسرائيل وهذه العلاقه
مع حكومه تينياهو
لكن هنالك عده خطوط يجب على رئيس الوزراء
ان لا يعبرها راينا لافين الذي كان وزير
العداله
تقول انه لا يبطئوا العمليه والا
سيخسر الزخم التدخل بايدن الان يهدف الى
ان اسرائيل يبقى بلد على رغم من ان
الولايات المتحده لديها نفوذ قوي عليها
لكنها تريد الولايات المتحده تريد ان تبقى
هذا
النفوذ نوعا ما هو امر مثير للاهتمام لان
الشعب الاسرائيلي
ينتفضونهم ويحتاجون وهي باعداد تاريخيه من
اجل دعم الديمقراطيه ويظهرون على ان
نتنياهو ان لا يقوم بالدفع بهذا التشريع
وان الرد
الصحيح يجب ان يكون من احزاب اللكود نرى
انها نحن لا نعتقد ان هذه القانون سي لانه
اذا ما تم الموافقه عليه ربما سيكون هنالك
الكثير من الاضطرابات وايضا راينا ايضا
ردا قويا من
العسكريين في قوات الاحتياط هم يرفضوا
تمريض هذا القانون بدون مداولات كافيه لكن
لدينا هذه القضيه الحكومه تحاول ان تدفع
به والحزب يمكن ان يتدمر ان ينهار هنالك
الكثير من الاشخاص الذين هم
مسيرتهم المهنيه على
المحق لان لكنهم
يريدون ان يرفضوا ويقاوموا هذا القانون
وايضا هنالك قضيه بايدن يريد ان يبقي
السيطره السياسيه على اسرائيل وهو عنصر
اخر عندما نظر اليه بعين جدليه وندرك انه
عنصر اخر من تدخل الولايات المتحده في
الحياه السياسيه في الشرق الاوسط لكن كما
قلت ان الديمقراطيه قويه
وهنالك ايضا شد وجذب بين الاطراف المختلفه
في ايجاد حل ولكن الحلول قد تصل في
اللحظات الاخيره كما ذكر زميلي قد نرى ردا
لكن بايدن يحاول ان يسيطر على هذا الامر
ايضا ويبقي نفودا الولايات المتحده كما
ذكرت بسبب العنصر الامني فان هنالك احتمال
لا سمح الله من انتفاضه اخرى لاننا نرى
الكثير من المناوشات والكثير من الردود في
المنطقه التي اذا تم النظر الى اسرائيل
دوله ضعيفه قد يسبب مشاكل بالتالي راينا
وزير الدفاع الذي ضحى
بحياته السياسيه من اجل ان يقاوم هذا
القانون الذي يراه تهديدا
للحياه الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل
في هذه الحاله واعذريني سيد لاسال ضيفي من
الناصره امير مخول الان المفتاح في يد من
هل هو في يد رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو اذا ما تصورنا السيناريو التالي
وتم ازاحه وزير الدفاع نظرا لموقفه المعبر
عنه من قبله هل سينتهي السيناريو عند هذه
الاقاله ام هناك تداعيات اخرى ايضا اذكر
هنا ايضا المذكره القضائيه التي قدمت في
حق
نتنياهو تطالبه وتتابعه في مساله ما يسمى
بغابه عني المصطلح القضائي ولكن متابعه
قضائيه لانه تدخل من خلال مصرفي ما يتعلق
بهذه التغييرات القضائيه وهو رجل متابع
قضائيا ثم لا يخونه منصبه لان يكون جزءا
من هذه المطالبه بهذه التغييرات اذا اين
يقف المشهد عقب او في حال ما اذا تم اقاله
وزير الدفاع
يعني الازمه الاسرائيليه بدات كازما
سياسيه بين احزاب او التشكيل الحكوميه
لكنها تحولت الى ازمه دوله عميقه جدا
وازمه متدحرجه لا يمكن رؤيه نهايتها بعد
ولا تداعياتها بعد
ستكون اكثر شراسه في الموضوع الفلسطيني
فيما تعتبره صحته الداخليه وما الى ذلك
الاسرى 48 وستكون اضعف استراتيجيا على
مستوى اقليمي على مستوى عالمي وهذا ما
يبرز
السيناريوه طبعا مفتوحه لا زالت يعني قد
يكون هناك قرار من المحكمه العليا
يمنع او يلغي هذه القوانين وعندها ستكون
هناك فوضى في الحكم يعني الجيش والمؤسس
الامنيه ستكون معتمده الى القانون وليس
الى الحاكم وليس الى الوزير او رئيس
الحكومه وهذا سيؤدي الى نوع من انقسام في
المنظومات الاسرائيليه وهذا ما يحذرون منه
في المؤسسه الامنيه لكن في نهايه المطاف
انا دائما هناك من يحدد سياسه الحكومه
اليوم اكثر من اي طرف اخر من ناحيه فعليه
وجدول الاعمال الحكومه هو بن جبير بس يجب
ان يكون ذلك واضحا لان لديه مال ليس موضوع
ليس ما يشغلهما هو الاصلاح تغيير القضائي
او اصلاح القضايا او الانقلاب القضائي
وانما ما يشغلهما هو مشاريع اخرى مشاريع
الضمه مشاريع
تصفيه
ولا لا يكترثون لاي موقف دولي ولا لاي
موقف عربي ولا لاي اتفاقيات
كان لديهم مرجعيات دينيه الفقهيه من غلات
المستوطنين من بعض من تنظيم الارهاب
اليهودي الذي كان في الثمانينات وهما يعني
يعملون في في عقيد ارهابيه متماسكه ولديهم
مشروع كبير كبير في حسم القضيه الفلسطينيه
هذا ما يشغلهم ليس يعني وهذا ما يجب ان
نشغله الفلسطينيون والعرب انه عمليا يجب
ان ننظر ما وراء هذه
التغييرات لانها ليست هي الهدف لعده ياهو
الذي يريد ان تتخلص من حكمه او من محاكمته
ولا عند بن كبير يريد ان نتخلص من فلسطيني
في النقب والساحل ولا في مشروع الضم الذي
يسعى اليه والحسم الذي يسعى من الناصر
امير مخول الكاتب والباحث المختص في اشياء
ان الاسرائيلي وكذلك لضيف مثل تل ابيب
الدكتور دار نشفتان رئيس برنامج دراسات
الامن القومي في جامعه حيث وكذلك ضيفتي من
روما ميشيل عضو الحزب الديمقراطي الامريكي
وخبيره في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
كتاب هذه الحلقه بالبرنامج ما وراء الخبر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]